next question today hey David is the
left going overboard with purity tests
in the 2020 Democratic primary well
let's first examine what purity tests
there are and before we can even do that
let the it's important to point out
policy questions are only called purity
tests when there are disagreements about
the position what what I mean by that is
once it's uncontroversial that everyone
in a certain party or country or
movement or whatever holds the same
position it's no longer called a purity
test it's just called common sense I'll
give you an example there's a democratic
purity test you could call it that that
if you're for slavery you can't be the
nominee no serious Democratic
presidential primary contender can be in
favor of slavery in the United States
why isn't it called a purity test
because slavery is in the Democratic
Party no longer controversial it's no
longer debated there were points in
American history at which time your
position on owning slaves would have
been controversial and at a certain
point in that period of negotiation it
might have become a quote purity test
now that it's no longer controversial we
don't call it a period yes so let's be
careful just of the branding of position
questions as purity tests now now that
we've gotten that out of the way let's
talk about what people might be
referring to in the Democratic primary
as far as as what could be considered a
purity test health care more and more is
a so-called purity test in the
Democratic primary it's not problematic
and it's not extreme so to go back to
the question is the the Democratic Party
going overboard with purity tests at
this point in time you cannot seriously
claim to be a progressive in 2019 when
so many countries have all sorts of
different versions of health care
systems that get way more people health
care at a lower cost than we do in the
United States the German model the
British model the Canadian model the
Nordic model the Swiss model it is not
serious to be a progressive and yet
that we should have a for-profit health
care system and that merely toying
around with Obamacare is going to get us
where we need to be so is it a damaging
purity test quote purity test that at
this point in time if you're only paying
lip service to health care for everybody
you are probably not actually a serious
progressive I don't think it's
problematic whatsoever call it a purity
test or not increasingly it's sort of
not because any serious contender is
taking some kind of healthcare for all
position I don't think that's a damaging
purity test there is one potentially
problematic at the national presidential
level purity test and it's not
problematic ideologically it's
problematic only pragmatically which is
that of taking corporate PAC money now I
want to be really clear here I don't
want I know people are gonna say David
are you saying you're in favor of taking
corporate PAC money no I think that it
shouldn't even be allowed I think the
entire system is corrupt from the ground
up and it needs to be rebuilt in such a
way that corporate PAC money isn't even
a thing we need time limits on Elections
Public Finance and you know all the
stuff that I've talked about but we know
that at the Congressional level you can
win even easily without taking any
corporate PAC money we've seen it done
many many times
at the national presidential level I am
wondering not concern trolling I'm
genuinely wondering are you a
unilaterally disarming yourself if you
say you're not going to take corporate
PAC money can you win I hope that the
answer is yes but I have that question
mark and so I I think that it's a
possibly damaging purity test corporate
PAC money not in that I think there's
any serious moral or ethical debate
about whether anybody should be taking
corporate PAC money or whether it even
should be allowed what we know is that
the reality is that if you raise a lot
more money you're more likely to win
this is even more pronounced in
presidential campaigns I would be
concerned that the Democratic candidate
if they do not take corporate PAC money
it's putting themselves in a position to
get Donald Trump reelected to another
four years I don't know the answer I'm
genuinely asking you is that a problem
but big picture oftentimes when people
talk about purity tests they're talking
about issues that are increasingly not
controversial within a group in this
case the democratic party that they want
to see as controversial so they call it
a purity test rather than common sense
not a problem other than this pragmatic
issue around PAC money and not
unilaterally disarming when we know that
fundraising is such a key issue in
determining who wins an election one of
today's David Pakman show sponsors is
simple habit an app that provides a
massive library of really excellent five
minute guided meditations they're
letting everybody in our audience use it
completely free for one week when you go
to simple habit comm slash Pakman we've
talked a lot on the program about the
growing scientific evidence pointing to
the benefits of meditation and what
really sets simple habit apart is the
variety of guided meditations that they
offer more than 2,000 made for many
different issues that you may be dealing
with if you need help falling asleep if
you have anxiety that you're dealing
with if you want to be more productive
during the day they have meditations
specifically tailored for certain times
of day like when you're waking up or
your commute to work or when you've just
gotten home from work I'm a huge
advocate of meditation myself I've
really enjoyed integrating simple habit
into my day and each meditation takes
just five minutes and they're very easy
to follow maybe you want to feel more
grounded before you start your day at
work or at school maybe you want to keep
your mind a little more clear so that
it's easier to accomplish your goals or
you just want a calmer more peaceful
experience throughout your day simple
habit can help you get there it just won
the 2018 Google Play award for best
well-being app it's available on Android
iOS and web browser and you can try it
completely free for a week check it out
go to simple habit calm slash Pakman
I've put a link down below underneath
the video